because it's like
and i have to say i saw zack snyder's
justice league
on the hbo max last night wow and i
expected nothing from it i i actually
thought
that it was the a new movie
you know i mean it was like something
like drink the pandemic
that they shot it or something you know
what i mean and then i thought
huh they made me put it on hold
and they were gonna release it last year
i don't know what the situation was but
i literally thought it was a new movie
so i looked at it
as if it was a new movie and and i after
it was four hours long
and after i was done with it i literally
laid in bed and i said that was probably
better that one of the best
superhero movies i've ever seen oh he
would love that it was
really good and um but then i realized
because there were moments in the movie
where i was like oh that seems familiar
to me but i don't know
maybe it's a feeling of nostalgia or
whatever but it was actually
a re-edited version of the piece of [ __ ]
that i saw joss whedon
four years like three years ago yeah the
josh whedon one
he just added and made it his own he
added
cut strength jokes he added hours
of you know me unseen footage and he
edited in a way where it was just like
it was just really good i can't explain
it it was like
i thought it went into depth with every
character i knew
cyborg a lot more i um i enjoyed some of
the jokes i think
the flash is very funny in it yeah who
plays the flash
he's cute ezra miller yeah he's really
good he's a funny guy he would like him
coletta he's a very funny guy in the
movie and um
i just really enjoy it you guys haven't
seen that yet right no but i'm glad
that zack snyder was allowed to do that
because you know like the reason why he
stopped was his daughter committed
suicide
and so what happened was debra this
producer his wife they stepped away from
the project
and i think part of his warner brothers
was not happy with the snyder cut
they were like this is too long and like
dark and boring we want it more like
marvel so they brought in joss whedon
when they were finding a replacement
so they joss whedon basically put the
jaw sweet in spin and made it more like
a an avengers film basically
and then the fans were pissed after the
movie came out
and for like a year they fought to give
snyder his own cut
and then the whole warner media thing
happened hbo needed more content yeah so
zack snyder was a lot of i think got a
70 million dollar budget to finish his
version of the movie
and they released it oh wow yeah because
it would it's completely different like
i remember now steppenwolf looks better
steppenwolf looks great
great right but i also remember it was a
band
yes and he's in and he's in it and he's
a god yeah he's in there
yeah steppenwolf was in it oh yeah the
the band it was weird in your head
you're like
how is you know me a musician
steppenwolf yeah the
main bad guy in it yeah and in the first
movie you're like
it doesn't make any sense but zach was
able to really make sense of it
you're so can i make an admission what
i have not seen a single
marvel or avengers justice league movie
hey yeah that's okay have you seen iron
man at least just the first
oh wait that's right i did something
okay i have seriously i haven't seen
iron man okay i honestly
i watch all the x-men does that make me
better
no uh those are great and also you've
never seen all of them
what all the experts yeah i haven't seen
the last two yeah the last two
yeah and you know what the worst one was
i wish i couldn't even finish phoenix
no that was terrible though the [ __ ]
the young mutants what was the oh the
horror film one no oh my gosh god it's
terrible
yeah and they have a great cast the
chick from um
maisie williams game of thrones yeah so
good and i finished my thought i'm just
i'm obsessed with her
[Laughter]
do you see queen's gambit no not yet she
never saw queen's gambit no she's
macy williams is not in queen's gambit
no but the girl that's in queensland
is in the new mutants
so you have maisie williams queen's
gambit lady who's
extremely talented you got to watch that
show it's great and
um and you're watching the first 10
minutes and you can
you already know oh this is a pile of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh man does it it's cut weird the
acting's terrible
they're both terrible in it it's a
terrible movie
you know they're talented people don't
get me wrong okay
and they're far more talented than i am
we'd love to have you on yeah but my
point is is that
you know when you you know tonight well
with because we're in the desert by the
way if people don't know
yeah yeah we haven't told anybody i
think the viewers know but the audio
list where's the [ __ ] desert
welcome welcome welcome to the desert
but i think that um tonight i would i'm
going to force you and jules to watch
it's always a forcing it's always his
choice
it's that good i'm not gonna honestly
sweetie um
it's not my number one choice as a
desert um
friday night watch it's more grounded
it's not like silly
but four hours it's just i don't you
don't want to see the musician's
steppenwolf do his thing
[Music]
all the hits hey guys we're gonna take a
really quick break to share
some of our favorite sponsors with you
four
hymns yeah you guys i'm now a member of
four hymns because my hair
is um it's falling out